[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily our
kelly survivors react to the disgraced
singer's 30-year sentence i'm grateful
that robert sylvester kelly is away i
will stay away and will not be able to
harm anyone else and missouri versus
rebecca rood
why were you looking at alternative
housing arrangements due to mainly the
fact that she was targeting
myself the victim's adopted mother
testifies as her biological mother
stands trial for the murder of her
daughter plus four arrests are made
after dozens of migrants are found dead
in a tractor trailer in texas and later
bill cosby speaks out one year after
he's released from prison long crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to long crime daily i'm
your host brian buckman for the first
time since r kelly's sentence is handed
down we're hearing from survivors who
say the sentence is one step closer to
receiving justice
on wednesday kelly was sentenced to 30
years in prison and slapped with a
hundred thousand dollar fine for a
string of sex crimes law and crime
network extensively covered his six-week
trial last fall where kelly was
convicted on nine federal accounts
notably at the trial multiple survivors
gave testimony detailing the brutal
sexual and physical violence they
experienced at the hand of kelly at
wednesday's sentencing hearing eight
victim impact statements were presented
where survivors said kelly lacked
remorse and used his celebrity status to
lure them into modern day slavery after
the sentence was handed down two of
kelly's survivors addressed the public
i never thought that i would be here to
see
him be held accountable for the
atrocious things that he did to children
i don't know what else to say except
that i'm grateful i'm grateful for today
and i'm grateful that robert sylvester
kelly is a way i will stay away and will
not be able to harm anyone else i
started this journey 30 years ago i was
14 years old when i encountered robert
sylvester kelly
there wasn't a day in my life
up until this moment that i actually
believed that the judicial system would
come through for black and brown girls
i stand here very proud
of my judicial system
very proud of my fellow survivors
and very pleased with the outcome 30
years did he do this in 30 years is what
he got
we also heard from federal prosecutors
and homeland security agents who
applauded the survivors for coming
forward with their stories
robert kelly once said
if you're going to tell your life story
you got to be honest or don't do it
over the course of this hsi led
multi-year investigation and six-week
trial a jury of mr kelly's peers
confirmed what these courageous victims
have known for a very long time mr kelly
is not an honest person this man is a
prolific serial predator who utilized
his status as a grammy award-winning
household name with global recognition
to inflict pain and anguish on so many
victims
despite numerous reports of his
destructive abuse over the years the
brazen acts of intimidation against his
accusers kept him shielded from
prosecution until
hsi
the u.s attorney's office from the
eastern district of new york and these
incredible prosecutors and nypd
initiated an investigation into his
criminal organization
today's sentence is a victory that
belongs to the brave victims who came
forward
despite intense public scrutiny
despite social media slander
despite threats to their own health and
safety
and despite being being asked to relive
the pain of some of the most traumatic
days in their lives they told their
stories and they made their voices heard
his attorneys also spoke following the
hearing saying their client maintains
his innocence and plans to appeal the
case he's due back in court in september
for a restitution hearing
joining us today is law and crime legal
analyst dina dahl and co-host terry
austin dino what appeals do you think
kelly will make and do they seem like
winnable ones to you
well we know that they're most likely
going to appeal the rico charged he was
convicted of the ricoh charge and for
sex trafficking and it's true that it
was probably a creative um
the ricoh charge was probably a pretty
creative charge because it requires them
to show that there was an enterprise and
not just that these were isolated
incidents but even if he is successful
in overturning that you know he would
still have his conviction of sex
trafficking and the prison time for that
would stand as well yeah now terry since
r kelly and elaine maxwell were
sentenced people have compared how the
judge in maxwell went lower in her
requested sentence and in kelly went
higher different judges similar crimes
is it right to compare the two well i
think we can compare the two it is
interesting the prosecution team
in the r kelly case asked for 25 and got
30 and the prosecution team in the
maxwell case asked for 30 and got 20.
but i do think the judges both donnelly
and nathan were looking at the same
thing they looked at the seriousness of
the crime they listened to the impact
statements they both applied the federal
sentencing guidelines and they both
considered the trauma that they each
experienced in their younger lives so i
think the analysis was the same but at
the end of the day i do think that kelly
got a bigger sentence because he was the
primary actor and maxwell we all know
was the one who was facilitating and not
the primary actor yeah makes sense um
apples and oranges a lot of similarities
but differences nonetheless
and switching to mississippi where a
team searching for evidence about the
lynching of a black teenager emmett till
found an unserved warrant for a woman
charged in his 1955 kidnapping
fourteen-year-old till was abducted
tortured and lynched more than 70 years
ago after being accused of flirting with
carolyn bryant a white woman at her
family's grocery store two men brian's
husband and his brother abducted till
beat him and shot him in the head before
dumping his body in the tallahatchie
river three days later his body was
found the two men were arrested but were
ultimately acquitted by an all-white
jury later they publicly admitted to his
killing but were protected by double
jeopardy the name on the arrest warrant
found last week is carolyn bryant
donahan the woman until allegedly
whistled at till's relatives who
initiated the search want authorities to
arrest her now 70 years later
investigators believe a woman possibly
brian identified till to the two men who
later killed him when asked if they
would prosecute the case the
prosecutor's office referenced a
december report from the justice
department which said no prosecution of
bryant is possible
still ahead on law and crime daily four
people are arrested and charged after
dozens of migrants are found dead in a
smuggling incident outside of san
antonio but first the victim's adoptive
mother testifies in the bench trial of
rebecca ruth charged in the death of her
16 year old daughter
[Music]
welcome back to long crime the judge
hears from the victim's adoptive mother
in the bench trial of missouri versus
rebecca rood just before the state and
defense rested wednesday rude is charged
with the 2017 murder of her 16 year old
daughter savannah lecky who was adopted
at birth by tamila leki montagu and
david leckie a couple who divorced
shortly before savannah's death savannah
who had special needs began struggling
with behavioral problems as a teen
leckie montague and rude agreed to have
savannah move back in with her
biological mother and her boyfriend
robert p
11 months later rude reported her
daughter missing prosecutors say rude
abused savannah and that she and pete
eventually killed her and burned her
body in june of 2017. investigators
searched their ozark county farm and
found bone fragments and teeth in a burn
pile in opening statements rude's
attorney argued savannah killed herself
and that rude admits to burning her
daughter on direct examination leckie
montague was asked what led to the
decision to move savannah elsewhere
did you look at alternative housing
arrangements for savannahs
was that why why were you looking at
alternative housing arrangements due to
mainly the fact that she was targeting
myself
extremely combative at home
very having lots of
confrontations with her siblings
one of the confrontations resulted in
my canada's son's father
showing enough concern that he was
talking about keeping him away from
um
did you and david talk about where to
place savannah
yes all right
did uh did you ask david to take
savannah
yes and and was he able to
he said
terry what did the prosecution get from
the adoptive mother in putting her on
the stand you know i think one of the
things the prosecution was trying to do
is show a motive this is a very sad case
savannah was not wanted by her real mom
she wasn't wanted by the adoptive
parents and here we have someone who has
special needs and i think the
prosecution was trying to say it was a
difficult person to handle that she was
getting combative and that that was the
very reason that her her own mother when
she went back to her own mother actually
killed her and you know the fact that
she was a teenager probably acting out
anyway didn't make things any easier
obviously not an excuse to kill someone
particularly in this heinous way but i
do think that was the purpose of showing
the adoptive mom on the stand yeah
dina i agree with that but the defense
attorney me is thinking no matter what
she says about rude my question to her
would be but you let savannah move in
with her right doesn't that mean that at
some point she thought that rebecca rude
was fit to be a mother
absolutely that or she has some
culpability herself some sort of at
least you know failure to um properly
take care of her daughter i mean it's a
really this story
just gets more and more tragic i agree
with terry she was failed by every
single adult in her life and the fact
that they knew that she was having
behavioral problems and then sent her to
her adoptive mother without knowing
whether or not her adopted mother could
handle it which clearly she couldn't
because she killed her or allegedly
closer within 11 months which is a very
short period of time
it just it shows such a failure of a
care by really any of these adults i
don't know if that really helped the
prosecution that much to me it just
really showed uh that maybe they should
be doing something even about what
her inaction was there certainly maybe
several adults here who failed her yeah
a lot of failure to be passed around and
unfortunately we have a young girl at
the middle but who suffered the most
well thank you both for your commentary
judge katanji brown jackson becomes the
first black woman supreme court justice
when she sworn in in thursday afternoon
back in april jackson was confirmed when
the senate voted on her nomination this
came after justice stephen breyer
announced his retirement on thursday
afternoon jackson took a constitutional
and judicial oath this makes jackson the
116th justice and the sixth woman to sit
on the high court
coming up on law and crime daily one
year after his release from prison bill
cosby speaks out plus four arrests are
made in the deadly migrant smuggling
incident out of texas that's ahead a
long crime daily
[Music]
welcome back four people are arrested in
connection to what authorities say is
the deadliest human smuggling incident
in united states history it happened
earlier this week when dozens of
migrants were found dead in the back of
an abandoned semi-tractor-trailer
officials say they died of heat-related
illnesses and exhaustion noting many of
the bodies were hot to the touch in all
53 people were died
officials say the people who were from
mexico guatemala and honduras were being
transported into the country in the back
of the semi without air conditioning or
water four people have now been arrested
in connection to the event officials say
forty-five-year-old jomero zolaro junior
was the driver of the semi and pretended
to be one of the injured migrants at the
scene he's now being charged with
smuggling resulting in death three other
people were also arrested including two
mexican men living undocumented in the
country officials say the sami was
registered to their address
terry based on these charges the death
penalty is on the table especially for
this smuggling resulting in death do you
think because of the number of deaths
the prosecutors will be seeking it oh
absolutely and in texas capital murder
is the only type of felony where you can
have the death penalty and they list out
all of the types of capital murder you
can have a murder for hire or if you
murder someone while you're in prison on
a life sentence if you're trying to
escape from prison if you kill a judge
in retaliation if you kill a police
officer or fireman so there are multiple
types but the very last listing type is
multiple deaths and here you have 53
deaths no doubt about it the prosecution
should not only seek the death penalty
but they should make sure that that jury
is ready to actually give the death
penalty it's hard to do but hopefully
they will be able to have a jury who can
actually give the death penalty because
this is a horrible case yeah terry i
agree dina viewers hear me out for a
second at least finish my sentence plain
devil's advocate but maybe we shouldn't
give them the death penalty maybe we
should give them lesser because and this
is the only reason why i say this maybe
we need them to flip on the people that
employed them because in my mind they
have already been replaced they already
have people who are gassing up the
trucks and doing this again don't we
want dina the people at the top of this
chain and not at the bottom
sir certainly we do and that's the one
way that maybe they can make some sort
of arrangement some plea deal and not
get the death penalty and put on there i
mean it's also possible these drivers
don't know that much information
sometimes organizations like this kind
of only give um an employee a small
amount of information they need to
complete their task so whether or not
they actually have kind of the goods and
can turn on the higher-ups is a big
question and if they don't i think they
will also get the death penalty as terry
mentioned also showing the kind of
significant depravity they showed her
that people they could have put in
really simple things like water bottles
in the truck or
fans in the truck if they really cared
at all about human life and the fact
that they didn't this would be a case
that they were going to apply the death
penalty i'm sure absolutely well and
down in texas a convicted killer is
facing four new capital murder
indictments that adds to the 18 capital
murder charges and two attempted capital
murder charges he's already facing in
the dallas area accused serial killer
billy shamirmir now faces charges in the
deaths of 22 women investigators
initially believed his alleged victims
died of natural causes it was only after
families reported stolen items and
suspicious circumstances that the cases
were reopened prosecutors say he
targeted senior living communities
smothered his victims to steal from them
a retrial was held in april for one case
the murder of looty harris after the
first jury was unable to reach a
unanimous verdict shamir mir was
convicted and sentenced to life in
prison without the possibility of parole
he is now in jail awaiting another trial
scheduled for october
when we come back bill cosby speaks out
what the disgraced comedian has to say
one year after his release from prison
[Music]
welcome back disgrace south carolina
attorney alec murdock is facing even
more charges in an alleged money
laundering and drug scheme prosecutors
say the once prominent lawyer was
involved in an eight-year money
laundering and painkiller drug ring they
say curtis eddie smith was also involved
in the alleged scheme he is the friend
and former client of murdoch who is
charged with trying to help him commit
suicide as part of a life insurance
fraud scheme last year the new charges
allege murdoch wrote more than 400
checks worth 2.4 million dollars smith
allegedly cashed them over the course of
eight years keeping some and spending
the rest on a wide range of illegal
activities prosecutors say that included
a distribution network for the
painkiller oxycodone this is the 16th
indictment against murdoch who faces a
slew of charges for alleged financial
crimes authorities are also
investigating the death of murdoch's
wife and son who were shot and killed on
their family property murdoch denies any
involvement in their deaths the new
indictment brings murdoch's total
charges to 81.
and we're hearing from comedian bill
cosby on the one year anniversary of his
release from prison back in 2018 the
disgraced comedian was convicted of
sexual assault he was sentenced to three
to ten years in prison last june the
pennsylvania supreme court overturned
cosby's conviction he was then released
from prison the court determined cosby's
due process rights were violated during
his conviction and that an agreement
with a former prosecutor meant charges
shouldn't have been filed in the first
place in a radio interview cosby
describes his release from prison
explaining what advice he gives to other
people in the same situation
i also discussed
that being of my race
and culture
uh many things
were against us and we had to work hard
to overcome these things
and people became our heroes and i said
heroes you've got to make yourself
heroes and then choose the correct
people
to be your heroes
this interview comes just one week after
cosby was found liable in a decades-old
sexual assault case he was ordered to
pay accuser judy huff five hundred
thousand dollars in damages
dina why do you think cosby is so happy
after losing a civil case should he be
in your opinion
you know i think anybody after being
released from prison early because their
conviction was overturned would be
ecstatic and a civil case for 500 000
for somebody like bill cosby it's really
not that much i imagine and he actually
didn't even attend the civil trial
because of his severe glaucoma so really
he just had to write a check to his
lawyers and then write a check for
damages and so i i think for somebody
with wealth that really probably doesn't
impact him especially if you've been in
in prison and you've been released you
probably see that all in a very
different light
i'm waiting for the day that losing 500
000 is not a big deal for me i lose five
dollars and it messes up my whole week
but hey whatever terry what's your
reaction to kazi celebrating his release
in this way well i think he should not
be celebrating obviously this is not a
victory for him he's out of prison yes
and that's good for him but it was
really a procedural issue that got him
out he had this agreement with this
prior prosecutor and he wasn't you know
they didn't abide by that agreement and
during his deposition he made some
admissions that shouldn't have been used
against him and so i think from a
procedural matter his due process was
violated and they came to the right
decision but he has no right to
celebrate from a substantive standpoint
you still have all of these accusers who
are accusing him and the way he did this
with all of these individuals using
drugs and basically taking advantage of
people it's no cause for celebration as
for the civil money look 500 000 i think
is a lot for anybody and you know that's
no reason to celebrate either so he's
happy i get it but i think he should be
more remorseful and quiet yeah we'll see
what he does maybe on the second
anniversary hopefully not as much of a
celebration well thank you both and
thank you for joining us here on law and
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you